Sal Khan here from Khan Academy what
you're seeing over the next few videos
are analyses of charts and data that
have put together by the New York Times
around trends in wealth income and
income inequality our goal here is to
give you extra context extra ways to
analyze the data maybe a lens that might
not be obvious when you first look at
some of these graphs now all of us here
at Khan Academy our goal we're
not-for-profit with a mission of
providing a free world-class education
for anyone anywhere is to provide the
supports so that you can look at the
data and come up with your own judgments
our goal is not to project any opinion
or any view onto you but to give you the
tools you need to form your own beliefs
or your own analyses so take a look at
these videos hopefully they will surface
insights on some of the data some of the
visualizations that might not have been
obvious otherwise and they inform all of
us on a very important debate in the
world and especially in this country
around how have incomes trended how has
the distribution changed over time and
where might we be going and for what
reasons